en toi de bonsoir vous êtes sur place
l'appel at il été entendu
oui tout à fait je suis sur place je
suis à l'entrée de la place où les
partisans d'alexina valley ont appelé
ses sympathisants à se rendre sitôt le
verdict annoncé alors pour l'instant
cela ressemble beaucoup au rassemblement
de dimanche dernier à savoir la place
qui est entièrement bouclé entièrement
verrouillé par les forces de l'ordre une
présence policière très importante dans
le centre de la capitale les quatre ou
cinq stations de métro les plus proches
ont été fermées résultat les gens se
pressent dans les avenues et dans les
rues adjacentes toutes ces avenues qui
mène vers cette place qui se trouve
réellement au coeur de la capitale russe
alors cet appel à descendre dans la rue
a été lancée sitôt le verdict annoncé un
verdict de trois ans et demi de prison
ferme pour rappel alexeï navalni avait
été condamné en 2014 dans une affaire de
détournement de fonds à trois ans et
demi de prison avec sursis et c'est donc
cette condamnation qui a été transformé
en peine de prison ferme alors vous
l'avez évoqué il ne va pas purgé cette
peine de trois ans et demi de prison
mais un petit peu moins car il a passé
quelques mois en résidence surveillée ce
sont donc deux ans et huit mois de
prison ferme qui l'attendent
antoine les réactions internationales ne
se sont pas fait attendre à la suite de
ce verdict
oui tout à fait les états unis par
exemple ont rapidement réagi via un
communiqué du secrétaire d'état qui a
appelé la russie à libérer immédiatement
et sans condition à l'excès la vanille
même son de cloche du côté de paris
emmanuel macron a même dans un tweet
déclaré qu'il était que cette
condamnation était inacceptable des
réactions similaires ont été entendus
également à berlin ou encore à londres
de quoi susciter une réaction de la
porte parole de la diplomatie russe
maria sharapova qui pour elle ces
réactions ne sont qu'un copier-coller
sergueï lavrov a également commenté cet
après midi la présence de diplomates
étrangers lors de l'audience d'alexei
cavaliers il a commenté en estimant
qu'il s'agissait là d'une interférence
dans les affaires internes à la russie
le kremlin a également réagi au cours de
la journée
il a dit que ce serait une bêtise si
l'union européenne venait à conditionner
ses relations avec la russie
au regard de la sphère navalni merci
antoine gayraud en direct de moscou